alright so Christopher you know work run
we're just days away from the wolf
America buck promise after you know
we're finally there and it's interesting
because we also last night it was we saw
this video with Chazz Palminteri and any
sort of answering the question who could
you trust in this business and his
immediate answer is nobody and then it
kind of goes on to clarify and I was
just sort of thinking in terms of this
screening coming up I can already sort
of envision folks coming up to me
afterward and kind of saying look babe I
really good film really touched me I
really loved it yeah even the even if
that's not the case either the film is
terrible idea I can still see number
coming up kind of doing that and I would
love to have maybe a question for
feedback yeah help me like a reasonable
question I just wondered you have any
thoughts on that in terms of what my
attitude should be or my approach to be
with others that night yeah I think like
to begin with it's all relative to
context so obviously after a world
premiere you know when you know your
heart what is the hearts on your sleeve
or whatever you're just so vulnerable
first and foremost no one's going to
want to critique you even constructively
so it's all about context so i would say
at something like a world premiere at a
vulnerable type context i would the best
you could do is perhaps one sign says
congratulation i love it i would just
say hey what exactly did you like so so
you could fish for particular xin terms
of constructive I mean positive feedback
like what resonate and then you could
ask why maybe not everyone is capable of
articulating why they like something so
what exactly what was your favorite
scene or which character did you like
most or what if they're a film type
person like which element which
production element really seemed to be
strong for you and why and then i would
say for the constructive critique which
i think it's a
that you want that because a lot of
people don't even though they say they
do I would say would be more in the
context of professionals responsible
people and smart people like people who
know film no film structured filmmaking
technique and who most importantly are
putting you first not their opinions not
their own voice not their own dumb ideas
but you what you want is a filmmaker
what you are trying to achieve and out
so that would be like invite some people
over watch your movie all come you know
watch movie let's have some wine and
talk about your movie constructively
people that you trust that create that
that's the beauty of like film school
again I didn't go to film squadron
really have that I did do drama and we
did that you know as an actor I stood in
front of the class after monologue and
just got shredded you know and but that
was amazing I grew as as a as an actor
because of that so I judges aids context
and then see you asking for clarifying
questions
you